he uses presto Walker I want to thank
Brian gehlbach who created and sent me
this fascinating problem at the
beautiful three geysers national park a
placard explains that it's three geysers
erupt at precise intervals of time
geyser a erupts exactly every two hours
geyser B erupts exactly every four hours
and geyser C erupts exactly every six
hours however you have no idea how the
three eruptions are staggered assuming
each geyser started erupting
independently at a random point in
history what are the probabilities that
each a B and C will be the first to
erupt after your arrival can you figure
it out give this problem a try and when
you're ready keep watching the video for
a solution so I first want to go over a
tempting but wrong answer to this
problem
suppose geyser eight erupted every two
hours on average and geyser be erupted
every four hours on average and geyser C
erupted every six hours on average this
is similar to how it takes to coin flips
on average to get a result of tails in a
12 hour period we would expect to see
six eruptions for a three eruptions for
B and two eruptions for C consequently
there are a total of eleven eruptions of
which six out of the eleven belong to
geyser a three out of the eleven
belonged to geyser B and two out of the
eleven belonged to geyser C so you could
use these as the probability that the
geyser would be the next one to erupt
however these values are not the answer
to this puzzle the reason is that the
geysers in this puzzle erupt at fixed
time intervals for example geyser C
erupts every six
if it erupted at 12 a.m. it would then
erupt at exactly 6 a.m. 12 p.m. 6 p.m.
and so on and the pattern would repeat
by contrast if geysers seat erupted 6
hours on average it would erupt at
random times like 5 21 11:45 a.m. 4:20
p.m. and so on but it would average out
to every 6 hours so how can we solve for
this puzzle which involves fixed time
intervals here's what we do first notice
the geyser 8 erupts every 2 hours so we
can be sure that some geyser erupts
within 2 hours
next geyser B erupts every 4 hours so
the probability that geyser beat erupts
within the next 2 hours will be 2/4 or
1/2
similarly geyser C erupts every 6 hours
so the probability of the guys RC erupts
in the next 2 hours is 2 out of 6 which
is 1/3 now in the next 2 hours there are
4 possible cases we know that geyser a
is going to erupt but geysers B or C may
or may not erupt within this time period
so we can enumerate the possibilities
the first is that all three will erupt
the next is that a and B erupt but C
does not the next is that a and C erupt
the B does not and finally we have that
a erupts but B and C do not erupt within
the next two hours now we're going to
create a little table that'll help us in
the calculation we're going to find the
probability of each of these cases and
then we're going to solve for the
probability that each one is the first
to erupt given one of the cases so let's
solve one of the cases and then we'll
work through the other ones so let's
start out with case 1 let's suppose that
all of the geysers a B and C erupt
within the next two hours what's the
probability that this happens well the
probability that they all erupt will be
the probability that a or
time's the probability that beer ups
times the probability that C erupts this
is because each is erupting at an
independent time so we can multiply
these probabilities and we get 1/2 times
1/3 which is 1/6 so that's this entry in
the table now
what's the probability that each one
will be the first to erupt given that we
know all three will erupt in the next
two hours well if all three erupt it is
equally likely that any of them could be
the first to erupt because we don't know
when the intervals are so the
probability that a B or C is the first
to erupt given this case 1 is equal to
1/3 so we figured out the first row of
this table now let's figure out case 2
we have a and B erupting but C does not
we first calculate the probability of
this which can be found by multiplying
the independent probabilities that a
erupts that B erupts and see does not
erupt we know the probability C erupts
is 1/3 within the next two hours
so the probability seed is not erupt in
the next two hours as 1 minus 1/3 so the
probability in this case is 1/2 times
2/3 which ends up being 1/3 now if a and
B erupt then either is equally likely to
be the first to erupt within this time
period so the probability that a or b
erupts to give in this case is 1/2 and
we know that seeds on erupt so the
probability of C given this case is
equal to 0 so we figured out the next
row of this table let's go to case 3
it's very similar to case 2 except we
have a and C erupt and B does not we
find the probability by multiplying the
probability that each does or does not
erupt given this interval we then
consider that if a and C erupt either is
equally likely to be the first so we
have the probability of a and C given
this case to be 1/2 and the probability
of B is equal to 0
finally we have the a erupts and B and C
do not the probability this is equal to
the probability that a erupts and B and
C do not this ends up being 1/3 and then
we have if only a erupts were sure that
a is going to be the first to erupt so
the probability of a given this case is
equal to 1 and the probability of B and
C given this case is equal to 0 so we
figured out all rows of this table we
can now do the calculation that we get
the probability that each geyser erupts
first we essentially need to take a dot
product between the probability of a
case and the probability of a geyser
given that case so for a we look at the
probability of each case and multiply it
by the conditional probability given the
case so the probability that a is the
first to erupt is 1/6 times 1/3 plus 1/3
times 1/2 plus 1/6 times 1/2 plus 1/3
times 1 and this also provides to be 23
over 36 which is approximately 63 0.9%
now we do the same thing for geyser B
and this all simplifies to be 2 over 9
which is approximately 22.2% finally for
geyser C we do the same thing and we end
up with 5 over 36 which is approximately
13.9% so there you go we figured out the
probability that each geyser erupts
first did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to our Channel I make videos
on math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic or puzzle you can email me
pressure and mind your decisions calm
and you can catch me on social media
either at mind your decisions or a
pressure Locker